Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. Bom dia! Today on our World Cup tour, we arrive, Dominic, at one of the great giants of the World Cup, don't we? Brazil. The greatest giant, I think people would say, Tom. The giantest giant. Yeah, absolutely. But Brazil is also, of course, a country that featured in a four-part special we did a few months back on the history of Portugal. Brazil, of course, was colonized by Portugal. And at one point during the Peninsular War, the entire Portuguese royal family got ferried across from Portugal by the British Navy to Brazil to escape the onslaught of Napoleon's French and
感谢收听《历史的余烬》。想要收听每周独家加更节目、无广告音频、抢先体验系列节目以及加入我们备受欢迎的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。早安！多米尼克，今天我们的世界杯之旅，来到了世界杯的一个伟大巨人，对吧？巴西。我想大家会说，这是最大的巨人，汤姆。最巨大的巨人。是的，绝对如此。但巴西当然也是一个在几个月前我们做的关于葡萄牙历史的四集特别节目中出现过的国家。巴西当然曾被葡萄牙殖民。在半岛战争期间，英国海军甚至曾把整个葡萄牙王室从葡萄牙用船护送到了巴西，以逃避拿破仑法军的猛烈进攻，
established an empire there. It became the capital of the entire Portuguese empire. And Portugal itself became a kind of colonial backwater. I mean, extraordinary development. And you promised us then, because we were focusing on Portugal, and once Brazil became independent, we rather left Brazil behind. But you promised us that we would do the history of the Brazilian empire. And that, unless I'm much mistaken, is what you have in store for us today. That's right, Tom. So it's a kind of spinoff, isn't it, from our Portuguese epic?
并在那里建立了一个帝国。它成了整个葡萄牙帝国的首都。而葡萄牙本土则变成了一种殖民地边缘地带。我的意思是，这是一个非凡的发展。当时你向我们承诺过——因为我们当时聚焦于葡萄牙，而一旦巴西独立，我们差不多就把巴西抛在脑后了——但你承诺过我们会讲述巴西帝国的历史。除非我记错了，这就是你今天要为我们准备的内容。没错，汤姆。所以这可以说是我们葡萄牙史诗的一个衍生剧，对吧？
It is really, yes. I mean, Brazilian listeners will be horrified to hear they're a spinoff. They would say Portugal is a spinoff, wouldn't they, Tom? But this is an extraordinary thing that people, I mean, everybody, when they think of the World Cup, and they think of football, they think of Brazil. Brazil is, I think, the world's fifth largest country, its seventh largest by population, by far the largest country in Latin America. And yet its history has so little traction in the British, the European, and I guess the American imagination. We know so little of it. And the real focus today is Brazil's second emperor, second and last emperor, Pedro II. And we'll come to him in a moment. So I'm guessing if he's the second emperor
确实是的，没错。我是说，巴西听众听到自己被说成是衍生剧会感到震惊的。他们会说葡萄牙才是衍生剧，对吧，汤姆？但这是一件非凡的事情，人们——我是说，每个人在想到世界杯和足球时，都会想到巴西。我认为巴西是世界第五大国土面积国家，人口第七大国家，是拉丁美洲迄今为止最大的国家。然而它的历史在英国、欧洲，我想还有美国人的想象中却几乎没有什么影响力。我们对它知之甚少。而我们今天的真正焦点是巴西的第二位皇帝，也是第二位兼最后一位皇帝，佩德罗二世。我们一会儿就会讲到他。所以我猜如果他是第二位皇帝，
that the first emperor was pedro the first would that be correct that's very that's very astute yes but yeah so the the extraordinary thing about brazil is that brazil is the one latin american country that begins as a monarchy it is not a republic so it became independent in 1822 um so the napoleonic wars are over and um as you described as we talked about in our portugal podcasts there is this there's been this sort of rising tension between portugal and brazil the portuguese kind of want their top status back they want their royal family back um dom jao who was the the king of Portugal, has gone back to Portugal. But the Brazilians, the Brazilian elite, I should say, the sort of, obviously, the Europeanized kind of elite, have thrown off the shackles of Portugal and proclaimed independence. Encouraged by this Portuguese king, right? I mean, he goes and he tells his son, declare independence.
那么第一位皇帝就是佩德罗一世，对吗？这非常非常敏锐，是的。但是，关于巴西最不寻常的一点是，巴西是唯一一个以君主制开端而不是以共和国开端的拉丁美洲国家。它于1822年独立，嗯……所以拿破仑战争已经结束了，嗯……正如你所描述的、正如我们在葡萄牙播客中讨论过的那样，葡萄牙和巴西之间曾有一种不断升温的紧张关系，葡萄牙人某种程度上希望夺回他们至高无上的地位，他们想要回他们的王室，嗯，多姆·若昂——曾担任葡萄牙国王的人——已经回到了葡萄牙。但巴西人，准确地说是巴西精英阶层——也就是那种显然被欧洲化的精英阶层——已经甩掉了葡萄牙的枷锁并宣布独立。在这个葡萄牙国王的鼓励下，对吧？我的意思是，他离开时告诉他的儿子，宣布独立。
Yes. Which is very treacherous behavior from a king. Well, he doesn't want his son and the court in Rio to be subject to this sort of liberal constitutionalism that is all the rage in Portugal. So what happens is 1822, Brazil has about 3 million people. Its wealth is based in exploitation, I suppose you would say. It's on gold and sugar from which the Portuguese have been profiting in suppose you would say. It's on gold and sugar from which the Portuguese have been profiting in the 18th century. It's also largely based on slavery. So Brazil has imported more slaves than anywhere else in the world.
是的。这对于一个国王来说是非常背叛的行为。嗯，他不希望他的儿子和在里约的朝廷受到这种风靡葡萄牙的自由主义立宪主义的支配。所以发生的事情是，1822年，巴西大约有300万人口。你可以说，它的财富建立在剥削之上。它建立在黄金和糖的基础上——葡萄牙人在18世纪一直从中获利。它在很大程度上也建立在奴隶制的基础之上。所以巴西进口的奴隶比世界上任何其他地方都要多。
11 times more than the United States of America, is that right? Yeah, something more than 10 times more or something like that went from Africa to Brazil than went to the United States of America. So exactly, isn't it interesting that when people have these conversations about and arguments and debates about the Atlantic slave trade, we think of it in terms of the Caribbean of Jamaica, or we think of it in terms of the United States and this great southern cotton plantations, but Brazil is kind of left out of the story by English speakers because we know so little about it. So this nascent monarchy has been formed under Dom Pedro, who is the Portuguese king's son. And he has proclaimed the defender of Brazil, the emperor of Brazil.
比美利坚合众国多11倍，是这样吗？对，比美利坚合众国从非洲运到巴西的人数多出10倍以上或者差不多的样子。所以没错，你不觉得这很有趣吗：当人们就跨大西洋奴隶贸易展开这些对话、争论和辩论时，我们往往会从加勒比地区、牙买加的角度去想，或者从美国及其南部盛大的棉花种植园的角度去想，但因为我们对巴西知之甚少，它就被排除在了英语使用者的故事之外。所以这个初生的君主国是在多姆·佩德罗的领导下建立的，他是葡萄牙国王的儿子。他被宣称为巴西的保护者、巴西的皇帝。
His proclamation of independence is very monarchist. He has a coronation, Tom, that you would very much appreciate. is it sacral it's very sacral he is anointed is it weird it is not weird i know you've been some weeks ago very unpatriotically making comments about the weirdness of the um it's not unpatriotic dominic weird is a perfectly respectable old english word wellveying a sense of the otherworldly and the supernatural. You resorted to strange, abstruse linguistic... No, not at all. ...justifications of your use of the word weird to describe the British monarchy,
他宣布独立的宣言非常具有君主制色彩。汤姆，他有一个你会非常欣赏的加冕典礼。它是神圣的吗？它非常神圣，他是被涂抹圣油的。这很奇怪吗？这并不奇怪。我知道几周前你曾非常不爱国地对英国君主制的怪异性发表过评论……多米尼克，这并非不爱国，“奇怪（weird）”是一个非常体面的古英语词汇，传达了一种超凡脱俗和超自然的感觉。你诉诸于奇怪的、深奥的语言……完全没有。……来为你用“奇怪”一词形容英国君主制做辩护，
which I thought was absolutely disgraceful. And the 10-page Daily Mail denunciation is forthcoming. But in the meantime, while we're still doing the podcast together, while you are still allowed to travel the country and not yet confined to house arrest enjoying the peace of good king charles exactly uh we should continue with brazil so he's anointed he has a don pedro has a ceremony which is based i read on um the kind of enthroning of pontiffs and of emperors and so on. He's anointed and consecrated with holy oil. But weird.
我认为这绝对是丑陋可耻的。长达10页的《每日邮报》谴责信即将出炉。但与此同时，在我们还在一起录播客的期间，在你仍然被允许在这个国家旅行、还没有被软禁在家里享受好国王查理的平静生活的时候……绝对的，嗯……我们应该继续讲巴西。所以他被涂抹圣油，多姆·佩德罗有一个仪式，我读到过，它是基于……嗯，教皇和皇帝登基等仪式。他被圣油涂抹和祝圣。但很奇怪。
Brazil is kind of- Properly weird. Yeah. It's completely reasonable and not weird at all. Is that correct? Right. So this is a very conservative state in many ways. It's unlike other what you might call revolutionary independent states.
巴西有点……恰到好处的奇怪。是的。这完全合情合理，一点也不奇怪。是这样吗？没错。所以这在许多方面是一个非常保守的国家。它不同于其他你可能称之为革命性的独立国家。
It is devoted to the monarchy, to slavery, and to defending the interests of the big kind of Brazilian landowning classes, the people who own gold mines and sugar plantations, and so on. And obviously, that issue of slavery, because we're in the 19th century, means there is to some extent a kind of time bomb at the heart of the kind of Brazilian constitution. So about a third of the population are slaves. And in some areas in Salvador, in the sort of northeast of Brazil, about 80% of the people in the city are slaves. Even in Rio, about 45% of the people, so about half the people there are slaves. So they are not kind of citizens. They are not members of the sort of political community of this new country.
它忠于君主制、忠于奴隶制，并致力于捍卫巴西庞大的地主阶层的利益，也就是那些拥有金矿和甘蔗种植园的人，等等。显然，奴隶制这个问题，因为我们正处于19世纪，意味着巴西宪法的核心在某种程度上埋藏了一颗定时炸弹。大约三分之一的人口是奴隶。在萨尔瓦多的一些地区，在巴西的东北部，城市里大约80%的人是奴隶。甚至在里约，大约45%的人，也就是那里大约一半的人都是奴隶。所以他们算不上是公民。他们不是这个新国家的政治共同体的成员。
So that seems equivalent of being for the slave owners to be the equivalent of camping out on the edge of a volcano. You would think so, yeah. How can, if 80% of the population are slaves are there revolts are there there are i mean spoiler alert there will be slave revolts in this podcast um yes exactly and but the part that the monarchy plays in this slavery question is probably not the part that anybody is going to expect who doesn't know the story already so we'll come to that so what they're trying to do is to create a new nation they have a state but they don't really have a nation so one way of doing that they have a new flag the flag of brazil everybody kind of is green and yellow um the green interestingly so
所以这在奴隶主看来，似乎等同于把营地扎在火山边缘。你可以这么认为，是的。怎么会……如果80%的人口都是奴隶，会有起义吗？会有吗？我的意思是，剧透一下，在这个播客里将会有奴隶起义……是的，完全如此。但君主制在这个奴隶制问题中所扮演的角色，可能不是任何不了解这个故事的人所预料的那样，所以我们稍后会讲到这一点。因此，他们正试图创建一个新的国家。他们有一个国家（state），但他们并不真正拥有一个民族（nation）。所以做到这一点的方法之一是，他们有了一面新国旗，巴西的国旗，每个人都知道它是绿黄相间的，有趣的是，绿色……
they the flag of brazil now is not quite the same as it was in the 1820s but it's similar so the green represents the house of braganza the portuguese royal family i always thought it was the jungle no and the yellow is the austrian imperial family i always thought it was the gold no no no it's real old world kind of um heraldry kind of stuff uh there's a diamond shape in the flag and that apparently is a tribute to napoleon i don't know why um that seems counterintuitive. Well. Since they ran away there to get away from him.
现在巴西的国旗与1820年代的不完全一样，但很相似。绿色代表布拉干萨王室，也就是葡萄牙王室。我一直以为那是丛林……不是的，黄色代表奥地利皇室。我一直以为那是黄金……不，不，不，那是真正的旧世界那种……纹章学的东西。国旗上有一个菱形，这显然是对拿破仑的致敬。我不知道为什么……这似乎有违直觉。好吧。既然他们逃到那里就是为了躲避他。
I suppose so, but people are very transfixed by Napoleon, aren't they, at the beginning of the... Especially once he's been tamed and defeated. Yeah, but we haven't got a reference to Napoleon on our flag. I mean, it's interesting. No, that's true. But it's interesting that Brazil is not a kingdom. It's an empire. So right from the beginning, it's interesting that Brazil is not a kingdom. It's an empire.
我想是的，但在……的初期，人们对拿破仑非常着迷，不是吗？尤其是当他被驯服并被击败之后。是的，但我们的国旗上可没有拿破仑的印记。我的意思是，这很有趣。不，这倒没错。但有趣的是，巴西不是一个王国。它是一个帝国。所以从一开始，有趣的是，巴西不是一个王国。它是一个帝国。
So right from the beginning, there's a kind of ambition to the foundation of Brazil. This is going to be a kind of Napoleonic empire in the Americas. Obviously, you don't just need a flag for a nation. You need a dynasty. So Dom Pedro, who is a very dissolute and useless person, really, who's only really interested in sort of his endless affairs with different kind of society women. I mean, we talked about him in our Portugal podcasts
所以从一开始，巴西的建立就有一种雄心壮志。这将是美洲的一个拿破仑式帝国。显然，一个国家不仅需要一面国旗。你需要一个王朝。所以多姆·佩德罗，一个非常放荡且毫无用处的人，实际上，他只对与各种名媛的无休止风流韵事感兴趣。我的意思是，我们在葡萄牙播客中谈到过他，
as having had chronic diarrhea when he was announcing. Yes. And that sort of sets the tone, I think, for his reign, I think it's fair to say. But he has a son in 1825, his wife, Donna Leopoldina. So she's from this sort of Austrian background, hence the flag. She gives birth to Dom Pedro, the future Dom Pedro II. And Dom Pedro II, who's going to dominate this podcast today,
说他在宣布独立时患有慢性腹泻。是的，我认为可以说，这为他的统治定下了基调。但在1825年，他的妻子多娜·利奥波迪娜为他生了一个儿子。所以她来自这种奥地利背景，因此才有了国旗的颜色。她生下了多姆·佩德罗，也就是未来的多姆·佩德罗二世。而多姆·佩德罗二世，将主导我们今天的播客，
the little boy, he is related to almost every royal family in Europe. So he can trace his descent from the kings of Castile and Aragon, from the kings of France, the kings of Hungary, from Maria Theresa of Austria. So this is a real, he is a sort of an icon of European royalty born in the Americas, an extraordinary kind of individual. So he's the future of the dynasty. But his father, Don Pedro I, useless, he's pretty much distracted. Yes, thank you for that, Tom. He is distracted pretty much straight away by Portugal
这个小男孩，他与欧洲几乎所有的王室都有亲戚关系。所以他可以将其血统追溯到卡斯蒂利亚和阿拉贡的国王、法国国王、匈牙利国王、奥地利的玛丽亚·特蕾西亚。所以这是一个真正的……他简直是出生在美洲的欧洲王室偶像，一个非凡的人物。所以他是王朝的未来。但他的父亲，多姆·佩德罗一世，毫无用处，他几乎立刻就分心了。是的，谢谢你指出这一点，汤姆。他几乎立刻就被葡萄牙分散了注意力，
because his father died back in Portugal and he wants to be king of Portugal. So he's sort of increasingly torn between Portugal and Brazil. In 1831, the sort of tensions that underlie his rule, is he content as emperor of Brazil, or does he really ultimately want to go back to Portugal and claim the throne of Portugal? These come out in the open. There are a lot of liberals.
因为他的父亲在葡萄牙去世了，他想成为葡萄牙国王。所以他在葡萄牙和巴西之间越来越心神不定。1831年，他统治之下的那种潜在紧张关系——他作为巴西皇帝是否心满意足，还是他最终真的想回到葡萄牙并宣称葡萄牙王位？这些都公开化了。有许多自由派人士。
This is among the elite, the sort of elite in cities like Rio. People who are reading newspapers and kind of go into salons and things like that, who kind of chafe a little bit at the idea of an absolute monarch. They sort of take to the streets and they start sort of shouting, long live the constitution, as people tend to do in the early years of the 19th century. There's a thing called the night of the bottles where people are all throwing bottles at each other. Yeah, people are throwing bottles at each other. I assume empty bottles rather than, I mean,
这是在精英阶层中，比如里约等城市的精英阶层。那些阅读报纸、参加沙龙之类活动的人，对绝对君主制的想法略感不满。他们走上街头，开始高喊“宪法万岁”，正如19世纪初人们往往会做的那样。有一个事件叫做“瓶子之夜”，大家互相扔瓶子。是的，人们互相扔瓶子。我猜是空瓶子，而不是……
it would seem utterly wasteful to be throwing bottles of wine or something at each other. Yeah, that would be a waste, wouldn't it? Yeah, it would be a terrible waste. And there's a sort of great groundswell of opinion against Don Pedro I. He says, right, I'm going to abdicate. and there's a sort of great groundswell of opinion against don pedro the first uh he says right i'm gonna abdicate so he abdicates he flounces off to portugal does he and he flounces off to portugal um so he he abdicates he says my son is now the emperor
互相扔几瓶葡萄酒或其他什么东西，看起来未免太奢侈了。是的，那太浪费了，对吧？是的，那将是极大的浪费。而且有一股反对多姆·佩德罗一世的巨大民意浪潮。他说，好吧，我要退位了……而且有一股反对多姆·佩德罗一世的巨大民意浪潮。他说，好吧，我要退位了。所以他退位了，气冲冲地去了葡萄牙，是吗？他气冲冲地去了葡萄牙，嗯……所以他退位了，说：“我儿子现在是皇帝了，”
even though his son is six five and a half six he's abdicated that's very irresponsible five and a half he says i'm off i'm out of here's very irresponsible. Five and a half. He says, I'm off. I'm out of here. I'm going off to Portugal. So he does go off to Portugal. He fights the civil war in Portugal to try and put his daughter on the throne of Portugal. So what's his plan? He's going to be the power behind the throne.
尽管他儿子只有六岁、五岁半。他退位了，这太不负责任了。五岁半。他说：“我走了，我离开这儿了。我要去葡萄牙。”所以他确实去了葡萄牙。他在葡萄牙打内战，试图把他的女儿推上葡萄牙王位。所以他的计划是什么？他要成为王位背后的权力操纵者。
The Portuguese have made it clear they don't want him as king. But he thinks, I'll put my daughter on the throne and i'll be the you know i'll be the big man um he dies of tuberculosis in the hour of his victory tom oh that's sad but interesting here's the thing here's a sort of portent of the future don pedro the first to be described as useless on his deathbed he writes an open letter to the people of brazil so he hasn't forgotten about brazil which is nice okay that's good and in the open letter he says slavery is an evil and an attack against the rights and dignity of the human species but its consequences are less harmful to those who suffer in captivity than to the nation whose laws allow slavery it is cancer that devours its morality so he's sort of pinning is saying you know the monarchy should not be should not be in favor of slavery, and slavery is very bad.
葡萄牙人已经明确表示不希望他当国王。但他认为，我要把女儿推上王位，而我将成为那个……你知道的，我将成为那个大人物，嗯……他在胜利的时刻死于结核病，汤姆。哦，这真令人难忘但又有趣。事情是这样的，这里有一个未来的预兆：多姆·佩德罗一世被描述为毫无用处，他在临终前写了一封给巴西人民的公开信。所以他没有忘记巴西，这很好。好吧，这很好。他在公开信中说：“奴隶制是一种邪恶，是对人类尊严和权利的攻击，但其后果对遭受囚禁的人造成的危害，小于对允许奴隶制的国家的危害。它是吞噬其道德的癌症。”所以他基本上是在表明……是说，你知道，君主制不应该、不应该赞成奴隶制，奴隶制是非常糟糕的。
Well, I'm sure the slaves are happy about that, but I'm not entirely sure they'd agree with him that they're better off than their owners. Yes, exactly. That's right. Who's the real victim here? Exactly. So anyway, Dom Pedro I is dead. Meanwhile, back in Brazil, the Brazilians are having to get used to their second emperor, who is not yet six years old. So poor little Don Pedro II, they bring him onto a balcony in Rio. He's so small, he can't kind of look over the balustrade. So they put him on a chair and he waves a hanky. They get him to wave a hanky to the crowds and everybody cheers and says hurrah, hurrah, hurrah.
好吧，我相信奴隶们对此很高兴，但我不太确定他们会同意他的看法，即他们的处境比他们的主人更好。是的，完全如此。没错。谁才是真正的受害者？绝对是的。无论如何，多姆·佩德罗一世死了。与此同时，在巴西，巴西人不得不习惯他们的第二位皇帝，他还不到六岁。所以可怜的小多姆·佩德罗二世，他们把他带到里约的一个阳台上。他太小了，以至于看不见栏杆外面。所以他们把他放在一张椅子上，让他挥舞手帕。他们让他向人群挥舞手帕，每个人都在欢呼，高喊“乌拉，乌拉，乌拉”。
But for him, this is very bad news. He's sent off to a palace called São Cristóvão with his two sisters, Francisca and Januária. January. Great name. Great, great name. And they basically are just sort of locked in this palace and given endless lessons.
但对他来说，这是一个非常糟糕的消息。他被送到了一个叫做圣克里斯托弗的宫殿里，和他的两个姐姐弗兰西斯卡和雅努亚里娅在一起。雅努亚里娅。好名字。非常非常好的名字。他们基本上就被锁在这个宫殿里，接受无穷无尽的课程。
So the Brazilians think it's very important that their future emperor, well, their current emperor, I suppose. And what are they teaching him? Lepidoptera? They teach him. Well, we know because we have a letter. Botany? There are very few sources, actually, Tom,
所以巴西人认为，他们的未来皇帝——嗯，他们当前的皇帝，我想——非常重要。他们在教他什么？鳞翅目昆虫学？他们在教他……嗯，我们知道，因为我们有一封信。植物学？实际上，汤姆，关于可怜的多姆·佩德罗二世的生平，资料非常少，
on the life of poor Dom Pedro II, because he's locked in his room the whole time, so we don't really know. But he writes a letter to his sister at one point in 1833, and he says, Writing, arithmetic, geography, drawing, French, English, music and dance divide our time. point and he's in 1833 and he says writing arithmetic geography drawing french english music and dance divide our time we work constantly to acquire knowledge and it is only these efforts that mitigate how sorely we miss you during our separation oh so he's not really allowed any
因为他一直被关在房间里，所以我们并不真正了解。但他在1833年的某个时候给他的姐姐写了一封信，他说：“写作、算术、地理、绘画、法语、英语、音乐和舞蹈占据了我们的时间。我们不断努力去获取知识，只有这些努力才能减轻我们在分离期间对你无比的思念。”哦，所以他基本上不被允许有任何
friends he's not really learning about rainforests or anything no no no he's learning european old world sort of stuff so he's sort of locked in his room doing arithmetic all the time he's pretty miserable he's pretty unhappy he's lonely um he's been separated from his parents he's kind of shy and he's reclusive so there's the emperor that he's the little boy who's the emperor of brazil meanwhile brazil itself is a bit of a, I wouldn't call it a basket case. That's too harsh. But you asked about slave revolts.
朋友，他其实并不是在了解热带雨林或其他什么东西。不，不，不。他学的是欧洲旧世界的那种东西。所以他基本上被锁在房间里，一直在做算术。他相当痛苦，相当不快乐，感到孤独，嗯……他与父母分开了，他既害羞又隐居。所以这就是那个皇帝，那个作为巴西皇帝的小男孩。与此同时，巴西本身有点……我不会称之为烂摊子，那太严厉了。但你刚才问到了奴隶起义。
There are an awful lot of slave revolts in the early decades of Brazilian independence. So the state of Pernambuco, there's a big revolt called the Cabanada Revolt. And that's, you've got Brazilian Indians, escaped slaves, squatters, people who've sort of been marginalized and forced out. They all come together and they form their own kind of community in the woods. And they kind of, they form their own army and they're always fighting off the landowners' attempts
在巴西独立的最初几十年里，有非常多的奴隶起义。所以在伯南布哥州，有一场被称为卡巴纳达起义的大规模起义。那是……那里有巴西印第安人、逃亡奴隶、擅自占地者，以及那些被边缘化和驱逐出境的人。他们走到一起，在树林里建立了他们自己的某种社区。他们以某种方式……组建了自己的军队，并且总是在击退地主们试图
to kind of put them down. And this is a real theme of 19th century Brazilianzilian history how long did they manage to hold out they held out for about four years i mean quite a long time yeah and this is absolutely that you know you see this pattern again and again so in the the big huge northern state of para in the late 1830s there's another revolt of again again, sort of Indians, slaves, and so on. And their slaves turn against their masters, and they whip them and kill them. And in the cities, there are huge sort of outpourings of hatred against the slaves and the Indians. And people say they're evil, they're the forces of the devil.
镇压他们的企图。这确实是19世纪巴西历史的一个主题。他们坚持了多久？他们坚持了大约四年。我的意思是，相当长的一段时间了。是的，绝对如此……你知道，你一次又一次地看到这种模式。所以在北部巨大的帕拉州，在1830年代末，又发生了一场起义，同样……又是印第安人、奴隶等等。他们的奴隶背叛了主人，鞭打并杀害了他们。在城市里，对奴隶和印第安人的仇恨情绪大规模爆发。人们说他们是邪恶的，他们是魔鬼的势力。
You know, this is what happened in Haiti, the Haitian Revolution. That will happen here in Brazil. The only way to deal with them is by intense violence and so on and so forth. And there was a colossal amount of violence. So in states like Pará, I think something like 100,000 people were killed. I mean, these are massive death tolls. I was about to say utterly unreported in the old world. That's not really true. But what is true, I suppose, is that they're utterly forgotten today.
你知道，海地发生的事情就是海地革命。这也会在巴西发生。对付他们的唯一方法就是采取极其暴力的手段，等等。当时确实有大量的暴力活动。所以在帕拉这样的州，我想大约有10万人被杀害。我的意思是，这是巨大的死亡人数。我正想说，这在旧世界完全没有被报道过。这其实并不真实。但我想，真实的情况是，它们在今天已经被彻底遗忘了。
So in Europe, people aren't even aware that these things happened. Well, presumably they are in Portugal. Yeah, I'm sure people know about it in Portugal. But we know about American history because we speak English. Right, I suppose that's true. I mean, that's the reason. A slave revolt that would really interest you is in the sort of northeastern state of bayern in 1835 famous city there which was a huge sort of trading sort of center for the slave trade salvador so there um there's an islamic element to the slave revolt so a lot of the african slaves who are being brought to bayern are mus. And Islam becomes the kind of the common ground
所以在欧洲，人们甚至不知道这些事情发生过。嗯，据推测葡萄牙人是知道的。是的，我确信葡萄牙人知道这件事。但我们了解美国历史是因为我们说英语。好吧，我想这是真的。我的意思是，这就是原因。有一场奴隶起义会让你真正感兴趣，那就是1835年东北部的巴伊亚州，那里有一个著名的城市，它是奴隶贸易的一个巨大贸易中心——萨尔瓦多。所以在那儿……奴隶起义中有一个伊斯兰元素，许多被带到巴伊亚的非洲奴隶都是穆斯林。伊斯兰教成了
for different groups of slaves so they can unite around their faith. So they wear white tunics, white prayer tunics. They wear amulets inscribed with verses from the Quran when they rise up. And of course, that then means that for the slave owners... It's a religious war. It's a religious war, exactly. So again, extremely violent. When that's put down,
不同奴隶群体的共同基础，因此他们可以围绕自己的信仰团结起来。所以他们穿着白色的束腰外衣，白色的祈祷服。起义时，他们佩戴刻有《古兰经》经文的护身符。当然，这意味着对于奴隶主来说……这是一场宗教战争。这绝对是一场宗教战争。所以同样地，极端暴力。起义被镇压后，
500 people are executed, publicly executed. Are there traces of Islam still in Salvador? That's a good question, Tom. I don't know. I don't know at all. Of course, the big story in Brazil has been the rise of Protestant evangelicalism. Yes. So originally a Catholic country, but... I just wondered whether... But I don't know. I'd be interested to find out actually um maybe so if we have brazilian listeners i don't think we ultimately do have any brazilian listeners but we do have a few tom
500人被处决，公开处决。萨尔瓦多现在还有伊斯兰教的痕迹吗？这是一个好问题，汤姆。我不知道。我完全不知道。当然，巴西的大事是新教福音派的兴起。是的。所以它最初是一个天主教国家，但……我只是想知道是否……但我不知道。实际上我很想了解一下。也许有吧。如果我们有巴西听众——虽然我觉得我们最终并没有什么巴西听众……但我们确实有几个，汤姆，
because we put out our brazilian independence episode yes so the story about the portuguese court on brazil's independence day and we had some listeners saying it was actually a complete coincidence wasn't it but we pretended it was by design and their brazilian listeners were very very excited um so there's a real sense at the end of the 1830s anyway that brazil is a bit of a sort of um it's in a terrible ferment with all this sort of stuff and the elites decide the way to deal with this is actually we need to crown the emperor even though he's still only a teenager if we put him in charge he will be a figure around whom everybody can can kind of
因为我们发布了巴西独立那一集。是的，关于巴西独立日那天葡萄牙宫廷的故事，我们有一些听众说这其实完全是个巧合，对吧？但我们假装这是精心安排的，巴西听众对此感到非常非常兴奋。所以在1830年代末期，确实有一种感觉，无论如何，巴西有点像处于……它正处于因所有这些事情而产生的可怕骚动之中，精英阶层决定应对这种情况的方法实际上是：我们需要为皇帝加冕。尽管他仍然只是个青少年，如果我们让他掌权，他将成为一个所有人都可以围绕着……
rally so it's 1841 and he is what he's he's about to turn 16 and they have this huge coronation ceremony um in rio uh all the newspapers sort of say he is the greatest man of his generation he is the new you know charles v or whatever he is a master of languages and of of education all this stuff because basically he's been locked in a school room for all his life so that all this sort of projection of him is the answer to all brazil's woes. It's interesting how they're still so kind of enthralled to European models. So they have huge medallions, four medallions for his models, Tom, and the people who he's going to emulate. And they are Charlemagne, François I of France, so Henry VIII's great rival, Napoleon, and sometime friend, sometime associate of the rest
团结起来的人物。所以那是1841年，他正要满16岁，他们在里约举行了盛大的加冕典礼。所有的报纸都说他是他那一代最伟大的人，他是新的……你知道的，查理五世或什么的。他是语言和教育的大师，所有这些东西，因为他基本上这一生都被关在学校里，所以所有关于他是巴西苦难解药的投射……有趣的是，他们仍然如此痴迷于欧洲模式。所以他们有巨大的奖章，为他的模范准备了四个奖章，汤姆，也就是他要效仿的人。他们是查理曼大帝、法国国王弗朗索瓦一世——也就是亨利八世的伟大对手——拿破仑，以及《历史的余烬》时而的朋友、时同盟的彼得大帝。这些人……你对此有何看法？嗯，我认为会有很多喧闹狂欢。但他听起来不像那种喜欢喧闹的人，对吧？不，他不是。弗朗索瓦一世和彼得大帝，他们都喜欢把侏儒扔来扔去，
of his history, Peter the Great. These are the people that... What do you think of that? Well, I think there'd be a lot of roistering. But he doesn't sound the kind of roistering kind, does he? No, he's not. François Premier and Peter the Great, both they love throwing a dwarf around
而且他们喜欢在花园里横冲直撞。是的，绝对很种族主义，诸如此类。查理曼大帝可不这样，他喜欢洗热水澡，喜欢泡在浴缸里和神职人员聊天。所以，我不知道，可以说和神职人员聊天是他的风格，对吧？是的，还有谁？拿破仑。嗯，我们对拿破仑很了解。对，公制单位。当你想到拿破仑时，首先想到的就是这个吗？公制单位？我该想什么？你曾为《每日邮报》写过稿。
and they're great rushing up a garden yeah yeah absolutely very racist and all that kind of charlemagne charlemagne not he liked a hot bath and and he'd hang out in the bath and chat to churchman so i don't know it's bad to say chatting to churchman is his thing isn't it yes and who is the other person napoleon Well, we know about Napoleon. Yeah, metric system. Is that what first comes into your mind when you think Napoleon? The metric system? What should I think of it? You wrote for the Daily Mail.
好吧，我应该吗？我的意思是，公制单位肯定是最伟大的拿破仑之举。最邪恶的罪行。是的。汤姆，你在和一个曾经写过专栏文章的人说话，那篇文章说采用十进制货币是英国……失去其民族灵魂的时刻。好吧，好吧，好吧，我能理解为什么那会是一个盘旋在你头上的阴影。好吧。
Well, should I? Well, but I mean, the metric system is surely the greatest of Napoleon's chorus. The greatest evil. Yeah. Tom, you're talking to a man who once wrote a column saying that the the adoption of decimal currency was the moment
那么……他在多大程度上符合这四个榜样？你知道吗？他表现得不算太差。现在有一个问题，他需要一个妻子。所以，
Britain lost its national soul so okay okay well I can see that why that's a shadow a shadow hanging over you all right so um
因为他……他可不是个软蛋。不是一个十足的软蛋。不。你会发现他可不是个十足的软蛋。在他加冕两年后，他们为他带来了一个妻子。她是两西西里的特蕾莎·玛丽亚·克里斯蒂娜公主。她来了。他之前被告知……
to what extent does he live up to these four role models do you know what he doesn't do too badly now there is one he needs a wife so
这非常像克里夫斯的安妮。他被告知她绝对是个大美人。“你知道，天哪，你会欣喜若狂的，你等不及了。”她到了，个子挺矮，身材相当胖，而且还有点瘸。嗯……据说他稳住了情绪，表现得足够镇定，在把她领进来时没有失态。但当她再次走出去时，他放声大哭。这对他们俩来说都很悲伤。他的总管拥抱了他，安慰他说：“记住你地位的尊严，尽到你的职责，我的孩子。”他尽责了吗？他确实尽了职责。实际上他很不走运，因为他的所有儿子都夭折了，但他留下了一个继承人，一个名叫伊莎贝拉的女儿，
because he's so he's not a milksop. Not a total milk. No. Well, you shall discover that he's not a total milksop. They bring over a wife for him two years after he's been crowned. She's Princess Teresa Maria Cristina of the two Sicilies. She comes over. He's been told.
我们稍后会讲到她。所以多姆·佩德罗二世，他是一个立宪君主。他拥有比英国君主更多的权力，但显然他没有沙皇或路易十四那样的权力。我想最大的压力是……路易十四什么的。我想，最大的压力就是奴隶制这个问题。所以为了让你对巴西的奴隶制有个概念，奴隶制在巴西社会结构中根深蒂固，以至于在1850年左右的里约热内卢，拥有的奴隶比……
It's very Anne of Cleves. He has been told she's an absolute beauty. You know, know god you're going to be over the moon you can't wait she arrives she's quite short she's quite large and she's lame and um okay it is said that he he composed himself he was sufficiently composed not to disgrace himself when she was brought in but when she went out again he burst into tears and um sad for both of them and his sort of major domo embraced him and kind of consoled him and said remember the dignity of your position do your duty my child and does he and he did do his duty actually he's very unlucky because all his sons died very young, but he was left with an heir, a daughter called Isabel,
据说自罗马帝国灭亡以来任何城市都要多。这是一个惊人的统计数据。这是一个惊人的事实。11万名奴隶生活在古代欧洲。比巴格达还多。显然是的。我的意思是，我可不编译我在互联网上发现的这些神秘事实，所以我不是……
who we will come to later on. So Don Pedro II, he's a kind of constitutional monarch. He's got more power than in Britain, but obviously he's not got the power of a czar or sort of Louis XIV or something like that. And I suppose the big sort of pressure is the 14th or something like that um and and the i suppose the big sort of pressure is this issue of slavery so just to give you a sense of of slavery in brazil slavery is so embedded in the brazilian social structure that rio de janeiro in let's say 1850 has more slaves
我想，实际上我是读过这个的。有一本精彩的书叫《巴西：一部传记》，作者是埃洛伊萨·斯塔林和莉莉娅·莫里茨·施瓦茨，我在讲葡萄牙的节目中提到过这本书。我认为这是关于巴西最权威的英文历史、学术历史。它对19世纪中叶那个世界的描写绝对精彩。为了让你对它有个大致概念：不仅前奴隶拥有奴隶，甚至连现役奴隶也拥有奴隶。那是罗马人的做法，罗马奴隶也拥有奴隶吗？嗯，这就是巴西的情况。我的意思是，它太根深蒂固了，这里是拉丁美洲，对吧？我们……我们是拉丁美洲。很好。但显然，由于英国人在国际上带头反对奴隶贸易，这种情况正面临压力。
than any city supposedly since the end of the Roman Empire. That's an amazing statistic. That is an amazing fact. So 110,000 slaves live in the ancient Europe. More than Baghdad. Apparently so. I mean, I don't compile these mysterious facts that I find on the internet, so I'm not.
巴西国内也出现了一种倾向，即鼓励移民而不是奴隶制。所以在19世纪中叶，政府开始鼓励来自欧洲的大量廉价劳动力大规模移民，以此作为奴隶贸易的替代方案。因此，这将会产生各种各样属于它自己的压力。而这些正是多姆·佩德罗现在真正掌握国家大权后必须应对的一些事情。那么，我们是否应该在第二部分看看他如何应对国家的权柄呢？这是一个好比喻吗，应对权柄？我挺喜欢的。我的意思是，总比像彼得大帝那样和侏儒摔跤要好。
I think, actually, I read this. There's a brilliant book called Brazil, a Biography by Eloisa Starling and Lilia Moritz-Schwartz, which I talked about in our Portuguese episodes. It's the definitive English language history, I think, of Brazil, academic history of Brazil. And it's absolutely brilliant on this sort of the world of the in the mid 19th century so to give you a sort of sense of it it's not just that former slaves own slaves but actual slaves own slaves that was a roman thing is that did roman slaves own slaves yeah well this is what they have in brazil i mean it's so embedded it's latin america right we Right. We're Latin America. Very good. But that obviously is coming under pressure because the British are moving internationally against the slave trade, for example.
是的。所以当我们回来时，将会有权柄摔跤。所以那是一个值得期待的看点。这很令人兴奋。再见。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《娱乐的余烬》。
And there's a move within Brazil to encourage immigration rather than slavery. So in the mid-19th century, you're starting to get the government encouraging lots of massive immigration of cheap labor from Europe as an alternative to the slave trade. So that is going to create all kinds of pressures of its own. And those are some of the things that Don Pedro is going to have to wrestle with now that he has really taken the reins of his country. So should we look at his wrestling with the reins of his country in part two? Is that a good image, wrestling with the reins? Quite like it. I mean, it's better than wrestling with dwarves like his country in part two. Is that a good image, wrestling with the reins? I mean, it's better than wrestling with dwarves like Peter the Great or something.
这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论、一丝八卦的固定栏目。在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐业的神秘面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想收听无广告音频、加更节目并提前获得现场门票，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。
Yeah. So when we come back, there will be a rein wrestling. So something to look forward to there. That's exciting. Bye-bye. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment.
网址是 therestisentertainment.com。你好，欢迎回到我们的巴西特辑。我们正在关注巴西皇帝佩德罗二世的统治。多米尼克，在第一部分中，你简要提到了巴西北部萨尔瓦多的一场奴隶起义，那里许多奴隶都是穆斯林。我问过你，伊斯兰教在巴西是否仍有很大的存在感？在休息期间，我去博德利图书馆查阅了一下。你知道吗，在1.91亿的总人口中，巴西的穆斯林总数是多少？35,000人。天哪。所以非常非常少，不到1%。
It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, a splash of showbiz gossip, and on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes, and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com.
是的，真的微乎其微。显然，那些参与奴隶起义的穆斯林受到了非常强力的皈依劝导。所以他们基本上是被迫改信了天主教。天哪。因此，伊斯兰教的痕迹被彻底抹去了。现在的穆斯林基本上都是来自黎巴嫩和叙利亚的移民。是的。所以这说明了该系统暴力性的一些问题，对吧？
That's therestisentertainment.com. Hello, welcome back to our brazil special um we're looking at the reign of emperor pedro the second of brazil um and dominic in the first part we uh briefly you touched on a slave revolt in which uh in salvador in north brazil where lots of the slaves were Muslim. And I asked you, does Islam still have much of a presence in Brazil? And during the break, I went to the Bodleian and I checked. And do you know, out of a population of 191 million, the total number of Muslims in Brazil, 35,000. Crikey. So very, very small, under 1%.
是的，确实如此。他们能够如此彻底地压制奴隶的宗教信仰。是的。所以，佩德罗二世真正想做的是建立一种独特的巴西民族文化。正是在他的庇护下，他鼓励各种巴西作家、画家等去创造一种关于“巴西性”的理念。而这个理念的核心是，奴隶制根本不是故事的一部分。所以他做的是，他创造了一种特定热带文化的理念，里面充满了印第安人和葡萄牙人的形象，但奴隶却几乎完全缺席。
Yeah, really tiny. And apparently the Muslims that took part in the slave revolts were very aggressively proselytized. So they essentially forcibly converted to Catholicism. Crikey. So the trace elements of Islam were wiped out. And the Muslims now are basically immigrants from Lebanon and Syria. Yeah. So that tells you something about the violence of the system, right?
所以绘画方面，他们画了很多风景画，非常浪漫。他们现在开始意识到家门口大自然壮丽的景色了吗？是的。所以大自然，你一开始问过关于他和自然界的关系，大自然非常符合他的心意。所以现在他们开始关注美洲豹之类的事物了。没错。所以这些意象全都是各种异国水果和异国野兽。
Yes, it does. That they're able to suppress the slave's religion so completely. Yeah. So Pedro II, what he really wants to do is to create a unique Brazilian national culture. And it's under his aegis that he encourages all kinds of Brazilian writers and painters and so on to create a kind of idea of Brazilian-ness. And what it's going to be is slavery is not part of the story at all. So what he does is he kind of creates this idea of a specifically kind of tropical culture full of images of Indians and things and of the Portuguese, but the slaves are almost entirely absent.
你在许多巴西的风景画中都能看到这些。他本人是个非常书生气的人。所以他开始学习。他热爱语言。他有点像J.R.R.托尔金那样的人物，研究各种语言。研究芬兰语语法。但他不是……他热爱语言。他有点像J.R.R.托尔金那样的人物，研究各种语言语法。但他研究的不是芬兰语语法，而是图皮语和瓜拉尼语——也就是土著印第安人，嗯，巴西印第安人的语言，精英阶层中的其他人
So paintings, they do lots of landscapes and lots of kind of very romantic. And is it now that they're starting to wake up to the grandeur of the natural world on their doorstep? Yes. So the natural world is, you asked at the beginning about him and the natural world, and the natural world is very much his thing. So now they're getting to jaguars and things. Exactly. So the imagery is all kind of exotic fruits and exotic beasts.
对此不屑一顾，但皇帝对所有这些都非常感兴趣。他资助各种研究项目，从全欧洲引进德国植物学家、瑞典自然学家、矿物学家、语言学家和地质学家。他基本上出资让他们来到巴西，并制作这些装帧精美、图文并茂的……但我的意思是，这并不是什么全新事物，对吧？因为有一座非常著名且美丽的图书馆，我想在四年前左右被烧毁了。我认为，我想那可以追溯到葡萄牙王室家庭抵达巴西的早期。葡萄牙实际上拥有美丽的图书馆，汤姆。
You see these in lots of Brazilian kind of landscape paintings. He himself, he's very much a sort of bookish person. So he starts to learn. He loves languages. He's kind of like sort of J.R.R. Tolkien figure, studying lots of languages. Studying Finnish grammars. But he's not's a he loves languages he's kind of like sort of jr tolkien figure studying lots of languages grammar but he's not studying finnish grammars he's studying tupi and guarani so indigenous indian yeah brazilian indian languages which other people in the elite
太惊人了。是的，这非常符合传统。是的，它是……我想这是巴西皇帝曾经居住过的地方，所以那座图书馆的传统以及对学术和自然界兴趣的传统，在某种程度上是他必须从中汲取的东西。哦，绝对是的。而且我认为非常有趣的是——所以他在努力尝试的是，他是在把旧世界复制到新世界吗？嗯，不完全是。他赋予了它这种特色，这种热带文化和热带君主制。但他显然非常……你知道，对多姆·佩德罗二世来说，创造一种人们会将其与葡萄牙、西班牙、法国、德国、意大利或其他文化并列看待的巴西文化，是非常重要的，它属于同一种文化连续体，我想是这样的。至于科学，他对科学有着绝对的热情。他成为了巴西的第一位摄影师，因为他在1840年获得了一台非常早期的银版照相机。
regard with scorn but the emperor is really interested in all this sort of stuff he finances all kinds of research projects he brings over german botanists and sort of um swedish naturalists and mineralogists and linguists and geologists from all over europe and he basically pays for them to come to brazil and to produce these beautifully illustrated but he's i mean he's, so this isn't something completely new, is it? Because there's that, the very famous and beautiful library that burnt down, I think, four years ago, something like that. Which I think, I think dates to the kind of the early years of the arrival of the Portuguese family, royal family in Brazil. They have beautiful libraries in Portugal, actually, Tom.
嗤之以鼻，但皇帝对这类事情非常感兴趣，他资助各种研究项目，从全欧洲请来德国植物学家、瑞典自然学家、矿物学家、语言学家和地质学家，基本上是出资让他们来到巴西并创作出这些精美插图的创作，不过我的意思是，这并不是完全崭新的事物，对吧？因为那个非常著名且美丽的图书馆在大约四年前被烧毁了，我记得是这样。我认为，这可以追溯到葡萄牙王室抵达巴西的早期。事实上，葡萄牙有很漂亮的图书馆，汤姆。
Amazing. Yes, that's very much, much in in in the tradition yeah and it was it was um i think it's where the brazilian emperor stayed so so he so that tradition of that that library and that kind of tradition of scholarship and interest in the natural world to a degree is something that he's he must be picking up on from that oh absolutely and i think what's really interesting is that he's – so what he's trying to do, is he trying to reproduce the old world in the new? I mean, not quite. He's giving it this spin, this sort of tropical culture
太惊人了。是的，这非常符合传统，而且我认为这就是巴西皇帝居住的地方，所以他保留了那个图书馆的传统，某种程度上，这种学术传统以及对自然世界的兴趣，一定是从那里继承过来的。哦，绝对是的，而且我觉得非常有趣的是，他——他到底在做什么？他是想在新世界复制旧世界吗？我的意思是，也不完全是。他赋予了它这种特色，这种热带文化
and this tropical monarchy. But he's obviously very – you know, it's very important to Dom Pedro II that he creates a Brazilian culture that people will consider alongside, you know, Portuguese, Spanish, French, German, Italian culture, or whatever, that it's part of the same kind of continuum, I guess. And science, he's absolutely passionate about science. He's the first Brazilian photographer because he acquires a kind of very early daguerreotype camera in 1840.
以及这种热带君主制。但很明显，佩德罗二世非常——你知道的，对他来说，建立一种能与葡萄牙、西班牙、法国、德国、意大利等文化相提并论的巴西文化是非常重要的，他认为这是同一个延续的一部分。而且科学，他对科学有着绝对的热情。他是巴西的第一位摄影师，因为他在1840年获得了一种非常早期的银版摄影机。
He sets up a photo laboratory in his palace in Sao Cristobal. He also has a chemistry laboratory and a physics laboratory. He has an astronomical observatory. He has a saying that he likes to bring out and bore his courtiers with. He says, la science c'est moi. Well, Dominic, I'm just the in the bodleian that he apparently there was a um a meteorite that landed um in the badlands and he sent an expedition to try and find it that's exactly the kind of thing he did it was a five metric ton space rock wow did they get it so it was it it
他在圣克里斯托瓦尔的宫殿里建立了一个摄影实验室。他还有一个化学实验室和一个物理实验室。他有一个天文台。他有一句喜欢拿出来说、让他的朝臣们感到厌烦的名言。他说，科学就是我。好吧，多米尼克，我只是... 在博德利图书馆里，据说当年荒地里降落了一颗陨石，他派了一支探险队去试图找到它，这完全符合他的行事风格，那是一块五公吨重的太空岩石，哇，他们找到了吗？所以它... 它
landed in um uh 1784 and so when when um when pedro ii learned about the meteorite he organised a commission of engineers to relocate it to Rio and the trek lasted 126 days and it was taken to the National Museum the one with the library so there you go and I'm glad to say that that meteorite was among
降落在 1784 年，所以当... 当佩德罗二世得知这颗陨石的消息后，他组织了一个工程师委员会将其迁往里约，这次跋涉历时 126 天，它被运到了国家博物馆，也就是藏有图书馆的那家，所以就是这样，我很高兴地说，那颗陨石是
the objects that were left unscathed by the fire that destroyed the museum so it survived Tom, as somebody who likes science dinosaurs all that kind of business you would love don pedro the second he sounds great great guy he's he's a man of i'll tell you what he sounds like he sounds an absolutely ideal subject to be uh the hero of a magical realist novel yeah he absolutely is he absolutely is so he's very intellectual as well he writes writes to people like Victor Hugo, to Nietzsche, to Wagner, to all these people. They think he's brilliant. So his reputation in Europe, among the European lettered classes, could not be higher. He asked Wagner to write an opera that would be premiered in real would you say he is the pelle of he is the european monarchs very nice yes he's the pelle and rather than the neymar of um of of european style american monarchs so yeah, he asked Wagner to write an opera. Wagner was too busy, so he couldn't.
在摧毁博物馆的大火中完好无损幸存下来的物品之一，所以它幸存了下来。汤姆，作为一个喜欢科学、恐龙和所有这类事物的人，你会喜欢堂·佩德罗二世的，听起来他是个绝佳的人选，他听起来... 我告诉你他听起来像什么，他听起来绝对是成为魔幻现实主义小说男主角的理想人选。是的，他绝对是，他绝对是。所以他也很博学，他给维克多·雨果、尼采、瓦格纳以及所有这些名人写信。他们认为他才华横溢。因此，他在欧洲文化界精英中的声誉可以说是无出其右。他曾要求瓦格纳创作一部将在...首演的歌剧，你会说他是...的贝利吗？他是欧洲君主中的...太棒了，是的，他是美洲风格君主的贝利，而不是内马尔...所以，是的，他邀请瓦格纳写一部歌剧。瓦格纳太忙了，所以没能写。
However, supposedly, when they did the whole ring cycle at Bayreuth in 1876, Don Pedro II was present. We should come on to his European travels in due course. And he sat next to the new emperor of Germany at the premiere. So this is not the Kaiser, Tom, friend of the rest of his history, great yachting enthusiast and shoe wearer. It's his grandfather, Kaiser Wilhelm I. And Don Pedro ruins the opera for everybody by constantly saying to all the other bigwigs,
然而，据说在 1876 年拜罗伊特上演整部《尼伯龙根的指环》时，堂·佩德罗二世也在场。我们稍后会讲到他的欧洲之旅。在首映式上，他坐在新任德国皇帝的旁边。所以这不是威廉二世，汤姆，那个《余烬未熄》的朋友、伟大的游艇爱好者和鞋子穿戴者。而是他的祖父，德皇威廉一世。堂·佩德罗不断对其他大人物说三道四，把整场歌剧给毁了，
he says, oh, I'm very familiar with this music. This is the first time you've heard it, but I know it by heart. I know all about this. You don't need to tell me anything about wagner i know wagner i love wagner wagner's my friend and all this kind of thing yeah this drives everybody else completely completely mad so in other words his reputation is sky high brazil itself um they fight a terrible incredibly bloody war called the War of the Triple Alliance in Paraguay in the 1860s, which apart from being bloody, it's very useful for Brazil because it creates this sort of image of Brazilian nationalism and of the sort of united fatherland and all this sort of stuff. But obviously, there is this issue of slavery. Now, let's get to the 1870s. Brazil has about 10 million people by now. And between 10
他说，哦，我对这段音乐非常熟悉。这是你们第一次听到，但我已经烂熟于心了。我对这一切了如指掌。你们不需要告诉我关于瓦格纳的任何事情，我了解瓦格纳，我热爱瓦格纳，瓦格纳是我的朋友，诸如此类的话。是的，这把其他人逼得彻底发疯。换句话说，他的声誉如日中天。巴西本土...他们在 18世纪60 年代在巴拉圭打了一场可怕且极其血腥的战争，被称为三国同盟战争，这场战争除了血腥之外，对巴西也非常有用，因为它营造了一种巴西民族主义、团结的祖国之类的形象。但很明显，这里存在奴隶制的问题。现在，让我们进入 1870 年代。到目前为止，巴西大约有 1000 万人口。而在 10%
and 20% of them, I think, are slaves. But the epicenter of slavery has slightly moved. Because what's changed with Brazil is before we were talking about gold and we're talking about the mining, but the big thing in Brazil now is coffee. So coffee is produced in the south of Brazil. And that's where the sort of the epicenter of slavery has really has moved to. The big landowners are based in the south around Rio and Sao Paulo. And in those in the big sort of the four southernmost provinces, about just under two thirds of the population are slaves. Now, the emperor himself, Don Pedro II, personally, is not in favor of slavery at all.
到 20% 之间的人口，我认为都是奴隶。但奴隶制的中心略有转移。因为巴西发生的变化是，以前我们讨论的是黄金和采矿业，但现在巴西最重要的事情是咖啡。所以咖啡产自巴西南部。而这正是奴隶制的中心真正转移到的地方。大庄园主们的基地位于南部里约热内卢和圣保罗周边。在那四个最南端的省份中，大约近三分之二的人口是奴隶。现在，皇帝本人，堂·佩德罗二世，个人根本不支持奴隶制。
He never bought slaves. He inherited 40 slaves, and he set them all free as soon as he could. He would often write to friends, and he would say he doesn't like slavery. Slavery is a terrible curse on my nation, he would say. But he was always inhibited um from moving against it because he's worried about alienating the elite he thinks the elite who own the slaves he depends on them for his power um so brazil is sort of slowly beginning to change so they do things like there's a law of free birth in 1871, which is that basically all children of slaves will be freed.
他从未买过奴隶。他继承了 40 个奴隶，并在条件允许时尽快释放了他们所有人。他经常给朋友写信，说他不喜欢奴隶制。他会说，奴隶制是对我国家的一个可怕诅咒。但他总是受到阻碍，无法对其实施行动，因为他担心疏远精英阶层，他认为拥有奴隶的精英阶层是他权力的支柱... 所以巴西开始慢慢发生变化，因此他们做了一些事情，比如 1871 年的《自由出生法》，基本上就是所有奴隶的孩子都将获得自由。
They have to stay with their mothers until they're eight. And then their owners, the mother's owner can choose between being compensated by the state then and there and the child is set free at the age of eight. Or they can continue to use the child's services until the child turns 21. So this is hardly, you know, kind of overnight abolition, but even so, it begins to alienate the big kind of coffee elites, the slave owners, because they start to think, well, if the government can do this, the monarch is not to be trusted. The monarch is going to end up abolishing slavery completely. This is all a very bad thing. So what you get in the 1870s is something that I think a lot of listeners may consider, may find a bit weird,
他们必须和母亲待到八岁。然后他们的主人，即母亲的主人，可以选择是在当时获得国家赔偿，并让孩子在八岁时获得自由；或者他们可以继续使用孩子的劳动力，直到孩子满 21 岁。所以这简直谈不上是...你知道的，一夜之间废除奴隶制，即便如此，它还是开始疏远那些主要的咖啡精英、奴隶主，因为他们开始认为，如果政府能做到这一点，君主就不可信了。君主最终会彻底废除奴隶制。这可真是一件糟糕透顶的事。所以在 1870 年代，你看到的情况是，我认为许多听众可能会觉得有点奇怪，
which is that what you'd call the kind of liberal elite, i.e. the people who read newspapers, who go to the opera, who are sophisticated people of the world, people who are well-traveled. These people start to flirt with republicanism and become interested in republicanism because they equate republicanism with the defense of slavery. So in other words, something that you might think of as very progressive becomes identified with a cause that could hardly be more reactionary. So there's this sort of sense in the 1870s that for all his amazing scientific stuff, interferometer rights. Sourcing, yeah.
那就是所谓的自由主义精英，也就是那些阅读报纸、去歌剧院、是世界见多识广的成熟人士、游历广泛的人。这些人开始对共和主义产生好感，并对共和主义感兴趣，因为他们将共和主义与捍卫奴隶制等同起来。换句话说，你可能认为非常进步的东西，却与一个再反动不过的事业联系在了一起。所以在 1870 年代，有一种感觉，尽管他做了所有这些惊人的科学研究，干涉权。来源，是的。
Yeah, being a fan of Wagner, all this kind of stuff, that the emperor is losing support among the very people that he really most needs um to keep his regime going do the slaves not love him well yeah the slaves do do quite as we'll discover the slaves do quite like the emperor because they see him as the sort of face of of the the abolitionist movement which is perhaps um a slight misreading of it because he doesn't really do that much to encourage abolition but so you start to get mockery of ped II. People, they have some very strange names for him, actually. His opponents call him Pedro Banana.
是的，作为瓦格纳的粉丝，所有这些事情，皇帝正在失去他最需要的那些人的支持，以维持他的政权。奴隶们不爱他吗？哦，是的，奴隶们确实...正如我们将要发现的，奴隶们确实相当喜欢皇帝，因为他们视他为废奴运动的化身，这也许...稍微有点误读，因为他实际上并没有做太多事情来鼓励废奴，但你开始听到对佩德罗二世的嘲弄。人们，事实上他们给他起了几个非常奇怪的名字。他的反对者称他为“香蕉佩德罗”。
Why? Seems very harsh. Well, they say his head is very long. He has a very long head. He looks like a banana. Right, okay. Maybe his sort of Habsburg blood or something like that. Yeah.
为什么？听起来很苛刻。嗯，他们说他的头很长。他有一个非常长的头。他看起来像根香蕉。好吧，明白了。也许是他那哈布斯堡家族的血统之类的。是的。
And the way they used to call Pericles the squid. The squid. They also call him Pedro the squid the squid they also call pedro the cashew would you rather be cashew or banana tom um i think i think cashew i think a cashew as well i think i'd much rather be likened to a cashew i think a banana is just an undecorous isn't it yeah if you're gonna be likened to a fruit of any kind louis philippe in france was likened to a pear yeah and um chan kai shek was likened to a pear. Yeah. And Chiang Kai-shek was likened to a peanut, wasn't he? Was he?
就像他们以前称伯里克利为乌贼一样。乌贼。他们还叫他“乌贼佩德罗”，他们还叫他“腰果佩德罗”。汤姆，你愿意当腰果还是香蕉？嗯...我想...我想当腰果，我也觉得腰果挺好。我觉得我更愿意被比作腰果，我觉得香蕉未免不太体面，对吧？是的，如果你非要被比作某种水果的话。法兰克的路易-菲利普曾被比作梨，还有...蒋介石曾被比作梨。是的。而蒋介石曾被比作花生，不是吗？是吗？
By General Sitwell. Oh, yes, of course he was. Yes, he used to call them a peanut. Yeah. So there's a whole podcast to be done about emperors and nuts. Fruit and nut-based abuse is the real theme there that we can perhaps run with a bit later on. It definitely is.
西世威将军说的。哦，是的，当然是。是的，他过去常叫他们花生。是的。所以关于皇帝和坚果，还有一整期播客可以做。以水果和坚果为主题的辱骂才是真正的核心主题，我们也许稍后可以接着聊聊。确实如此。
Yeah. So the elites, the sort of liberal elites, think that Don Pedro is unsound on slavery. They also think he's unsound on travel because in the 1870s, he starts to go traveling a lot and they think this is very bad and very unpatriotic and he should be more interested in Brazil, but he keeps sort of going for these jaunts around Europe. So he goes to America. So Tom, would you believe he is the first ruling monarch to set foot in the United States? But not the first to set foot in North America
是的。所以精英们，也就是所谓的自由派精英，认为堂·佩德罗在奴隶制问题上不够稳妥。他们还认为他在旅行方面不够稳妥，因为在 1870 年代，他开始频繁外出旅行，他们认为这非常糟糕，非常不爱国，他应该对巴西更感兴趣，但他却不断去欧洲各地游玩。所以他去了美洲。那么汤姆，你敢相信他是第一位踏上美国土地的在位君主吗？但不是第一位踏上北美土地的君主
because of Mexico, who we did a whole episode on, didn't we? We did. So when Ulysses S. Grant opens the World's Fair in Philadelphia in 1876, Don Pedro II is standing by his side i mean the world's fair he loves all that science machines yeah displays of international travel international travel exactly he goes to visit alexander graham bell and allows him to test his first telephone which is very nice he goes off to france he goes to visit victor hug He visits Victor Hugo at his house. There's a lovely story here, Tom.
因为墨西哥，我们之前专门做过一期节目，不是吗？是的。所以当尤利西斯·S·格兰特于 1876 年在费城开办世界博览会时，堂·佩德罗二世就站在他的身旁。我的意思是，世博会，他热爱所有的科学机器、国际旅行的展示、国际旅行，确实如此。他去拜访了亚历山大·格雷厄姆·贝尔，并允许他测试他的第一台电话，这非常好。他去了法国，去拜访了维克多·雨果。他在维克多·雨果的家中拜访了他。这里有一个美好的故事，汤姆。
Victor Hugo's daughter shows him in and says, Papa, here is His Majesty from Brazil. And Dom Pedro II says, My dear, there is only one majesty here, and it is Victor Hugo. Oh, that's splendid. I like him. Isn't that good?
维克多·雨果的女儿带他进去并说道：“爸爸，这是来自巴西的陛下。”而堂·佩德罗二世说：“亲爱的，这里只有一个陛下，那就是维克多·雨果。”噢，太精彩了。我喜欢他。这难道不棒吗？
And Victor Hugo says... No, I really like him. He sources meteorites, and he's polite to great French novelists. He is. Victor Hugo said to him, Sire, you are a great man. You are the grandson of Marcus Aurelius. Isn't that a nice thing to hear? Yeah, fabulous.
维克多·雨果对他说……不，我真的很喜欢他。他搜寻陨石，而且对伟大的法国小说家很有礼貌。他是的。维克多·雨果对他说：“陛下，您是一个伟人。您是马克·奥勒留的孙子。”听到这样的话难道不是很美好吗？是的，太棒了。
Everything. I mean, this is all very good. All very, very good. I hope it doesn't go wrong. It's going to end badly, Tom. Oh, no. I just wanted, I think, I feel like i don't want you to think i don't want it to come as too much as a shock when don pedro's life ends in misery as it will so he gets back to brazil and um the brazilians you know they
一切。我的意思是，这都非常好。非常非常的好。希望它不会出差错。事情会以悲剧收场，汤姆。噢，不。我只是希望...我觉得...我不希望你觉得...我不希望当堂·佩德罗的人生以悲剧告终时，给你带来太大的打击，事实确实如此。所以他回到了巴西，并且...巴西人，你知道的，
they're very displeased by all this behavior. They say, by this stage, he's grown a massive beard. He's got glasses. He doesn't look... They're sort of puffed up, I think, a little bit with a sense of sort of national destiny. And they think he's an unprepossessing monarch. He's too interested in books and science and stuff. And he's unsound, as they think, on slavery, on the defense of slavery. And so they're sort of losing enthusiasm for him. A few years go by. 1887, he goes on another of his trips. So this time he goes and visits Louis Pasteur, I do believe.
他们对所有这些行为非常不满。他们说，在这个阶段，他已经留起了巨大的胡子。他戴着眼镜。他看起来不像... 我想他们有点因为一种国家命运感而洋洋自得。他们认为他是一个不起眼的君主。他对书籍、科学之类的东西太感兴趣了。而且他在奴隶制问题上不够稳妥，在捍卫奴隶制方面也是如此。所以他们开始对失去对他的热情。几年过去了。1887 年，他又踏上了旅程。这一次，我相信他是去拜访路易·巴斯德了。
And he spends a lot of time in Europe. He often goes under an assumed name when he's walking when he's traveling europe so he doesn't go as the emperor so i think the brazilians also think this is poor form they would like him to go in splendor whereas in fact he goes and stays in hotels under false names and spends his time writing poems and they basically think this is this is and also he's he's it's known that he's basically said to people, I love doing this. Left to me, I would just do this all the time.
他在欧洲度过了很长一段时间。当他在欧洲旅行时，他经常使用化名，所以他不是以皇帝的身份出行。所以我认为巴西人也觉得这样做有失风范，他们希望他能以盛装出行，而事实上他却化名住在酒店里，把时间花在写诗上，他们基本上认为这简直是……而且他……众所周知，他基本上对人们说过：“我喜欢这样做。如果由我决定，我就会一直这样下去。”
I'd much rather live in Europe than in Brazil and hang around with Victor Hugo. So meanwhile, while he's away, obviously the issue of slavery is still there. Slavery has been abolished in the United States since the 1860s. We're now in the 1880s. There's a real sense that it's on its last legs, not least because the age of mass immigration means that the Brazilian economy is not as dependent on slavery as it once was. There are rising slave revolts in the 1880s,
我宁愿住在欧洲也不愿住在巴西，和维克多·雨果厮混在一起。与此同时，在他离开期间，奴隶制问题显然依然存在。美国自 19 世纪 60 年代以来就已废除奴隶制。我们现在身处 19 世纪 80 年代。人们明显感觉到它已经日薄西山，这很大程度上是因为大规模移民时代意味着巴西经济不再像过去那样严重依赖奴隶制。19 世纪 80 年代，奴隶起义不断增加，
and eventually, basically, the Brazilian government passes a law overnight, May 1888, the remaining 700,000 slaves are emancipated kind of forthwith. So end of slavery. Now, the people who are really outraged about this are the coffee planters, the coffee elites of Rio and Sao Paulo. As far as they're concerned, they've lost their property. They blame the emperor. Actually, he's out of the country when it happens because he's on one of his tours. He's hanging out with Louis Pasteur. Right. But they say it's all his fault. He hasn't stuck up for us. He's a waste of space. He's got to go. There's also this huge thing in Brazil of positivism. The late 19th century, the idea of science and reform and all that kind of thing.
最终，巴西政府在一夜之间通过了一项法律，即 1888 年 5 月，剩余的 70 万奴隶随即获得了解放。奴隶制宣告结束。现在，对此真正感到愤怒的是咖啡种植园主，里约热内卢和圣保罗的咖啡精英们。在他们看来，他们失去了财产。他们责怪皇帝。事实上，事情发生时他并不在国内，因为他在进行一次巡游。他当时正和路易·巴斯德在一起。没错。但他们说这全怪他。他没有支持我们。他是个废物。他必须下台。巴西当时还有一股巨大的实证主义思潮。19世纪末，科学、改革等各种理念盛行。
That has a massive traction with the kind of Brazil, the Brazilian educated classes, I guess, because it's about anti-clericalism. So and so and this turns against the idea of emperors, does it? Against the idea of emperors, that kind of positivism, republicanism, secularism, this sort of beautiful new future, which just so neatly, you know, happens to align with their interests. Exactly. So there's all this sort of stuff about the positivism and the republicans, and they're all kind of meetings and conspiracies. He gets back to Brazil, and in 1889, on the 9th of, 1889, he has a ball called the Ball on Fiscal Island. So this is a particular island. And he goes, it's basically to welcome the Chilean Navy who are visiting Brazil.
这在巴西知识分子阶层中产生了巨大的吸引力，我想，因为这关乎反教权主义。所以，这是否引发了对君主制观念的反对？反对君主制观念，那种实证主义、共和主义、世俗主义，那种美丽的未来，恰好与他们的利益不谋而合。正是如此。所以关于实证主义和共和主义有各种各样的讨论，他们都在开会和密谋。他回到巴西，在 1889 年的 1889 年 9 月，他举办了一场名为“鱼岛舞会”的舞会。这是一个特定的岛屿。他去了，基本上是为了欢迎访问巴西的智利海军。
And he goes to this ball, and there are all kinds of rumors going around the city about this ball, that there are orgies happening, that he hasn't invited sufficient numbers of bigwigs, sort of liberal-minded bigwigs and so on. And while he's at the ball, the sort of Republican agitators have a meeting with officers in the Brazilian army. The Brazilian army, and this is a very bizarre thing to say about an army, the Brazilian army is a hotbed of positivism, Tom. The officers like nothing better than an evening chatting about positivist ideas they've got from Europe. So they basically, a whole load of young officers go to this old marshal
他去参加了这个舞会，城里流传着关于这个舞会的各种谣言，说那里正在举行狂欢，说他没有邀请足够数量的大人物，比如自由派的大人物等等。当他在舞会现场时，那些共和主义煽动者与巴西军队的军官们举行了一次会议。巴西军队，对于一支军队来说这真是个奇怪的说法，巴西军队是实证主义的温床，汤姆。军官们最喜欢的事情莫过于晚上聊天探讨从欧洲学来的实证主义思想。所以他们基本上，一大群年轻军官去找了这个老元帅，
who's called Deodoro de Fonseca. They go to his house and they say, you know, the cause of positivism and of Brazil, it's time to get rid of the emperor. This old fool is at his party. We should move against him. The marshal Deodoro da Fonseca, he sort of drags his heels a bit, but eventually agrees to do it. So five days later on the 14th of November, he rides to the army headquarters. It's all a bit confused. He proclaims this coup against the emperor with the words, long live his majesty, the emperor, the imperial family, and the army, which is obviously not the ideal launch for a republican coup. But nevertheless, he says, the government's got to go, we have a new regime and all this kind of stuff.
他叫德奥多罗·达·丰塞卡。他们来到他家说，你知道的，为了实证主义和巴西的事业，是时候摆脱皇帝了。这个老糊涂正在开派对。我们应该对他采取行动。元帅德奥多罗·达·丰塞卡起初有些犹豫不决，但最终同意了。因此，五天后的 11 月 14 日，他骑马前往陆军总部。这一切都有点混乱。他发动了针对皇帝的政变，并喊出了这样的口号：“皇帝陛下万岁，皇室万岁，军队万岁”，这显然不是发动共和政变的理想开端。尽管如此，他说，政府必须下台，我们有了新政权，诸如此类的话。
The emperor is up in his palace, and he's sort of, you know, thinking about meteorites. Yeah, exactly. He gets a telegram from the center of Rio saying there's been some kind of coup. And he says to his wife, oh, it's fine. He says, I'll go down to Rio, but when I arrive there, it'll all be over. It's just a storm in a teacup. He travels by train, and on the train, says, I'll go down to Rio, but when I arrive there, it'll all be over. It's just a storm in a teacup. He travels by train, and on the train, Tom,
皇帝正在他的宫殿里，他正在...你知道的，思考陨石问题。是的，正好。他收到来自里约市中心的一封电报，说发生了一场政变。他对妻子说，哦，没关系。他说，我会去里约，但当我到达那里时，一切都结束了。这只是茶杯里的风暴。他坐火车出行，在火车上，说：我会去里约，但当我到达那里时，一切都结束了。这只是茶杯里的风暴。他坐火车出行，在火车上，汤姆，
he'd be delighted to hear. He spends his time on the train. He takes it so seriously. He spends his time reading the latest scientific periodicals. So he gets to the center of Rio, and various sort of marquises and stuff present themselves, and they say, should we raise troops to suppress this coup? The emperor says, no, no, no, I know that this is nothing. I know the people of Brazil.
你会高兴听到这个。他在火车上消磨时间。他对此极其认真。他把时间花在阅读最新的科学期刊上。因此，当他到达里约市中心时，各种侯爵之流纷纷现身，他们说，我们要不要调集军队来镇压这场政变？皇帝说，不，不，不，我知道这算不了什么。我了解巴西人民。
This is absolutely nothing. Then eventually a load of officers pitch up at the palace. So on the 16th of November, and they say, actually, it is something we've decided that you and the rest of the imperial family should be banished. Now this is by no means, you know, this is quite small groups of people. this is by no means, you know, we're talking about quite small groups of people. This is by no means a mass uprising.
这根本不算什么。接着，一大群军官闯进了宫殿。于是在 11 月 16 日，他们说，其实这确实是一回事，我们决定你和皇室其他成员必须被驱逐出境。这绝不是，你知道的，这是一小群人。这绝不是，你知道的，我们在谈论相当小的一群人。这绝不是大规模起义。
This isn't the French Revolution. There are no kind of great mobs pouring through the streets because the emperor is actually pretty popular. But the emperor, I think partly because there's part of him that thinks this basically means a lot of time I can spend with Louis Pasteur. When they tell him this, he says, if it is so, then this will be my retirement. I've worked hard and I'm tired. It is time to
这不是法国大革命。没有成群结队的暴民涌上街头，因为皇帝实际上挺受欢迎的。但皇帝，我想部分是因为他内心深处觉得这基本上意味着他可以有很多时间陪伴路易·巴斯德。当他们把这个消息告诉他时，他说，既然如此，这就是我的退休生活了。我工作很努力，而且我很累。是时候
go and rest. And so unbelievably, without raising an army to defend himself or anything like this, he says, right, let's pack our bags. In fact, the only time he kind of gets angry is when the officers come back in a day later and they say um basically have you not have you not packed yet you've got it you've got to go now in the middle of the night and the emperor is very cross and he shouts at them and he says i am not an escaped slave i will not leave in the middle of the night and then he shouts all of you are mad but then he packs his bags anyway and he gets gets on the boat, and off he goes to Europe. And that's basically the end of him.
去休息了。因此，令人难以置信的是，他没有组建军队来保卫自己或做类似的事情，而是说，好吧，我们收拾行李吧。事实上，他唯一一次生气是在一天后军官们回来时，他们说，基本上，你们还没收拾好行李吗？你们必须走，现在，在半夜。皇帝非常生气，对他们大喊大叫，他说我不是逃跑的奴隶，我不会在半夜离开。接着他大喊你们都疯了。但随后他还是收拾了行李，登上了船，前往欧洲。这基本上就是他的结局。
And that's it. So he doesn't come to a terrible end. Actually, it's quite a happy story. Because he said he wanted, you know, he was. I think it's a disappointing end, Tom. He'd been good for Brazil. I thought he was going to have a horrible end in a dungeon or something. No, no, he doesn't have an end in a dungeon.
就是这样。所以他并没有落得个悲惨的下场。事实上，这是一个相当快乐的故事。因为他说他想要的，你知道的，他当时...我认为这是一个令人失望的结局，汤姆。他一直对巴西很好。我以为他会在地牢里度过悲惨的晚年什么的。不，不，他没有死在地牢里。
I'm happy about that. And what happens to his daughter? Well, she goes with him. Actually, she never wanted to be empress. And he didn't even want her to be a procedure then except he doesn't live very well we'll come on to what happens to him so this is 1889 i'll quote a brazilian writer about what happened next to brazil so in the century after they got rid of emperor don pedro ii the brazilian republic had 12 states of emergency, 17 institutional acts. The National Congress dissolved six times, 19 military revolutions, two presidential resignations,
我对此感到高兴。那他的女儿怎么样？嗯，她和他一起去了。事实上，她从来不想当女皇。他甚至不想让她成为一个...除了他过得并不太好，我们接下来会讲到他的遭遇。所以这是 1889 年，我引用一位巴西作家的话来描述巴西接下来的遭遇：在摆脱皇帝堂·佩德罗二世之后的世纪里，巴西共和国经历了 12 次紧急状态，17 项体制法令。国民议会解散了 6 次，19 次军事革命，2 次总统辞职，
three presidents prevented from assuming office, four presidents deposed, seven different constitutions, four dictatorships, and nine authoritarian governments. So I think it's fair to say Dom Pedro II was a relative oasis of stability. And in fact, you ask about the slaves and what the slaves thought of him. He was very popular among Brazil's kind of African population and Indian population. Exactly. So we did a podcast, what seems like an eternity ago about weird wars. one of the weird wars one of my choices was a war called the war of canudos in the 1890s written about in a brilliant book called the war at the end of the world by mario vargas yosa the peruvian novelist and this was a kind of there
3 名总统被阻止就职，4 名总统被废黜，7 部不同的宪法，4 个独裁政权和 9 个威权政府。所以我觉得可以说，堂·佩德罗二世是一个相对稳定的绿洲。事实上，你问到奴隶以及奴隶对他的看法。他在巴西的非洲裔和印第安人中非常受欢迎。没错。所以我们做过一期播客，感觉像是很久以前的事了，关于奇怪的战争。其中一场奇怪的战争，我的选择之一是 19 世纪 90 年代的坎努多斯战争，秘鲁小说家马里奥·巴尔加斯·略萨在一部精彩的书《世界末日之战》中写过这场战争。这是一场...
was a guy called antonio the counselor who led this kind of weird kind of religious commune and that appealed to former slaves. And there were thousands of them. And they fought this war in which 30,000 people died against the Brazilian government. And part of the appeal of his kind of commune and his millenarian religious movement was that an emperor, a king, would return.
有一个叫安东尼奥的顾问，他领导了一个奇怪的宗教公社，这吸引了前奴隶。那里有成千上万的人。他们为这场战争与巴西政府作战，3 万人丧生。他的公社和千禧年宗教运动之所以有吸引力，部分原因在于人们相信一个皇帝、一个国王会归来。
So it was a combination of Dom Pedro II and the lost king of Portugal, Sebastian, Dom Sebastião, from the 16th century. And this side, Dom Pedro II lived on lost King of Portugal, Sebastian, Dom Sebastião from the 16th century. And this Dom Pedro II lived on in the memory of lots of Brazilians as this kind of exiled enlightenment paragon. King over the water. Yeah, the king over the water who had presided over abolition.
所以这是堂·佩德罗二世与 16 世纪葡萄牙失踪国王塞巴斯蒂安（堂·塞巴斯蒂安）的结合。这个堂·佩德罗二世活在许多巴西人的记忆中，化作了一个被流放的启蒙楷模。水上的国王。是的，主持了废奴运动的水上国王。
So what happened to him? So he went off to Europe. It wasn't a great laugh, actually. He didn't hang out as much as he would have liked with scientists and novice because he's in very poor health. He suffered from what I think diabetes. Most people think he had diabetes. He didn't have much money because the Brazilians basically cut off all his money.
那么他怎么样了呢？所以他去了欧洲。其实并没有那么快乐。他没有像他希望的那样花那么多时间和科学家及...在一起，因为他的健康状况很糟糕。他患有我想是糖尿病的病。大多数人认为他有糖尿病。他没有多少钱，因为巴西人基本上切断了他所有的资金来源。
So he lived for only two years in Europe. So this sort of dream of a lovely retirement. That's sad. However, when he died in Paris, which he loved, of pneumonia in December 1891, the French,
所以他在欧洲只生活了两年。所以这种美好的退休梦。这真令人难过。然而，当他在他热爱的巴黎于 1891 年 12 月死于肺炎时，法国人
they're very good with dead monarchs, Tom. Aren't they the French? President Macron absolutely distinguished himself. Yes, he did. Not always a friend of the rest is history.
他们对死去的君主很有一套，汤姆。法国人不是很擅长这个吗？马克龙总统表现得非常出色。是的，他确实如此。并非总是《余烬未熄》的朋友。
Yeah. But he distinguished himself with his reaction to the death of the Queen. So the French stage a state funeral for don pedro ii uh where his his coffin was escorted by 30 000 french troops 30 000 goodness and 300 000 people stood in the pouring rain to to see it go well the french do the french do love a monarch they don't they? They love this. There are hundreds of wreaths and the message on
是的。但他对女王去世的反应表现得很出色。所以法国人为堂·佩德罗二世举行了一场国葬，他的灵柩由 3 万名法国士兵护送，3 万人，天哪，还有 30 万人冒着倾盆大雨站在那里，看它离去。法国人确实很喜欢君主，不是吗？他们喜欢这个。有数百个花圈，其中一个花圈上的留言
the wreath that stands out, there was one wreath that said, just said simply, from a Brazilian black on behalf of his race. Which sort of tells you about how... So then his coffin was taken by train to Portugal and he was buried alongside the other
格外引人注目，有一个花圈上面写着，非常简单：“来自一个巴西黑人，代表他的种族。”这基本上说明了……于是他的灵柩被火车运往葡萄牙，并与其他
Braganza monarchs. Because he didn't go back to brazil to brazil but interestingly he is pretty much regarded i think by a lot of ordinary brazilians as the greatest brazilian so he wins polls and things like that did they have um did they have an equivalent of the i don't think they did because we have one in portugal we often talk about that do they have i don't think they did in brazil i might be wrong so there's no this so there's no there's no um a kind of imperial party in brazil saying let's no bring back the uh bring back the imperial family the emperor but i think i mean i i you know i think brazil is a fascinating country obviously great footballing history but it'd be even more fascinating if it was an empire again don't you think tom yeah i mean at the moment i'm gonna pin my colors can i pin my colors to the mask yeah i'm not a massive admirer of bolsonaro no in fact i would i think i'd go as far as to say
布拉干萨王朝的君主们合葬在一起。因为他没有回到巴西……但有趣的是，许多普通巴西人基本上认为他是最伟大的巴西人，所以他在民意调查等评选中获胜。他们有没有……他们有没有相当于……的某种存在，我想他们没有，因为我们在葡萄牙有一个，我们经常谈论那个，他们有没有？我想巴西没有，我也许记错了。所以没有，所以没有……巴西没有那种帝制党说，不，把……把皇室和皇帝带回来。但我的意思是，我……你知道，我认为巴西是一个迷人的国家，显然有伟大的足球历史，但如果它再次成为一个帝国，将会更加迷人，你不觉得吗，汤姆？是的，我的意思是，眼下我要表明立场，我能表明我的立场吗，是的，我不是博索纳罗的狂热崇拜者，不，事实上，我甚至会说
he's not a friend of of the rest is history what about president lula he's got a great name um because he's he's because he was in prison wasn't he and now he was in prison um of the two i would i would i would pick lula i'll be honest with you but but given the choice of lula boltonero or or don pedro the second an emperor with an interest in meteorites who would you go for i'd go for the emperor well i always you know i'm a monarchy fan um um an emperor who an emperor yeah an emperor who like stages operas and um gives money to historical associations i think he'd be very he'd be very into dinosaurs as well i think he's is he a friend of the rest of history
他不是《余烬未熄》的朋友。卢拉总统怎么样？他有一个很棒的名字……因为他曾……因为他曾身陷囹圄，不是吗？现在他曾身陷囹圄……在这两者中，说实话，我会选择卢拉，但……鉴于卢拉、博索纳罗或堂·佩德罗二世之间的选择，一个对陨石感兴趣的皇帝，你会选谁？我会选皇帝。好吧，我一直都是……你知道的，我是君主制的粉丝……一个皇帝，一个皇帝，是的，一个像举办歌剧并向历史协会捐款的皇帝。我想他对恐龙也会非常感兴趣，我想他……他是《余烬未熄》的朋友吗？
i'd like to think he is yeah let's let's enthrone him as a friend of the rest of history right okay well that's wonderful yeah that's wonderful i i's wonderful. I need nothing about him at all. Nothing. So I really feel that I've educated myself here. You've gained a friend, I think is fair to say. I've gained knowledge and I've gained a friend. Oh, that's lovely. That is, you know, that can't be reckoned a waste of time.
我愿意认为他是，是的。让我们……让我们拥戴他为《余烬未熄》的朋友吧。好的，太棒了，是的，这太棒了。我对他的了解全无。一无所知。所以我真的觉得我在这里丰富了自己的知识。你收获了一个朋友，这样说很公平。我收获了知识，也收获了一个朋友。哦，这太美妙了。你知道，这绝对不能算作是浪费时间。
If anybody says this podcast is a waste of time, I'll be very shocked. I hope that everyone listening, likewise, has gained a friend, perhaps, in the form of Don Pedro and has maybe learned something, as I have done. So thank you all very much for listening. Thank you, Dominic, for, dare I call it, a tour de force? I think you should. I think I will. A tour de force.
如果有人说这个播客是浪费时间，我会非常震惊。我希望每一个听众也同样收获了一个朋友，也许就是堂·佩德罗的形象，并且可能像我一样学到了一些东西。非常感谢大家的收听。谢谢你，多米尼克，带来了一场，我敢称之为杰作的演讲吗？我想你应该这么说。我想我会的。这是一场杰作。
So thank you very much. Thank you all for listening. And we will be back very, very soon with more. Bye-bye. Adios. Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com.
非常感谢。谢谢大家的收听。我们很快就会带着更多内容回归。再见。阿迪达斯。感谢收听《余烬未熄》。想要获取独家节目、提前收听、无广告体验以及加入我们的聊天社区，请访问 restishistorypod.com。网址是 restishistorypod.com。
I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip, and on our Q&A we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《余烬未熄：娱乐篇》。这是你获取娱乐新闻、评论、一丝八卦的每周必看节目，在我们的问答环节中，我们拉开娱乐行业的帷幕，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚启动了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、独家节目和提前获取现场门票，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可发表评论。